[Music]
this week on fyi increasing numbers of
children are suffering from long-term
coveted symptoms we hear from those
taking their appeals for help directly
to the prime minister we feel ignored by
the government by doctors by schools
[Music]
and do we talk enough about being
bullied we hear from victims who say
it's time to speak up and beat the
bullies they didn't think that i
belonged in this country as such so they
would just say go back home to where you
belong
[Music]
this is fyi your weekly news show which
gives you a voice on the big issues we
all care about
so we all thought things were getting
back to normal but look at this
covert cases are rising again in the uk
and check this out 1.5 million children
and adults are experiencing covert
symptoms for weeks months even years
yeah it's called long covered
our investigation earlier this year
revealed kids suffering from long-term
symptoms weren't getting enough support
with many missing out on school
in some cases doctors didn't believe
they were suffering with long-term
symptoms
what they told me was just go back to
school and do some exercise and that was
it basically they didn't really want to
know anything else we caught up with
some kids suffering from long covid who
delivered letters appealing for more
help directly to the prime minister's
office at downing street
i suffer from long covert i'm not the
only one
on the 15th of september i was in
increasing pain and it wouldn't stop in
my left leg
so i've been to any several times
i can't go to school full time and i
have to go in this wheelchair i get
rashes i get heart palpitations chest
cramps headaches nausea
muscle aches
we feel ignored by the government by
doctors by schools by anyone that hasn't
gone through it themselves
we aren't being recognized mainly by the
government
and be ignored for our invisible
disability that's why we have come here
to try and help people have a better
understanding so that not as much people
will be in the same position that we are
in i think right now the support that we
are receiving is
not good enough we're hoping that
they're going to make mass mandatory
again
hoping to get the windows open in
schools free tests
i'm looking for kids getting jabs and
just
everyone being safe and wow there needs
to be more research going in everyone
can bounce back from covert and i think
we need to take notice of it
[Music]
the government says it's allocated 50
million pounds to help research the
long-term impacts of long covid and now
there are special clinics to help treat
long covered in children
let's hope that goes some way to helping
so every week more and more of you are
joining our fyi news club you or even
your whole school can sign up
members get the chance to report for fyi
and our friends at the weekly newspaper
first news and members are given free
resources to set up their own fyi news
club at their school and discuss the
latest program
and we know how you love to practice
your fake news effect detection skills
so this week brayden paid a surprise
visit to west acre middle school who
have joined the fyi news club
hello new student brayden ready for
assembly hi brayden do you want to go on
through that'll be amazing thanks thank
you
oh hello
hello
how are you guys you okay yeah you're
all right i'm here today because i've
heard from your teachers that you're
actually quite the good spotters of fake
news aren't you so i've got two stories
that i'm going to show you guys and
you've just got to tell me whether you
think it's fake use or [ __ ]
take a good look at this photo does it
show refugees fleeing fighting during
world war ii or ukrainians trying to
escape the russian invasion
the person who posted it claims this is
not a photo from 1941 this is a photo
from march 2022 with all the color taken
out for a chilling reminder of how
history repeats itself
but is it really a photo from recent
weeks
hands up you think it's fake okay right
who wants to come up
why do you think it's fake news mate
if it's in 2022
why would it be black and white because
these days it's not that black and white
isn't it usually yeah i can actually
reveal
it's actually fact
this was originally taken in colour this
year in ukraine someone took the colour
out of it to make the point that people
are still having to flee war now like
they had to do in 1941 during world war
ii
here's some more photos people are
sharing to show how sadly history
repeats itself
[Music]
do you reckon we do another one
i think so too
so we found this video being posted on
social media by a man claiming that
abandoned cars blockages and checkpoints
in the ukrainian capital city of kiev
have been placed there as props like on
a movie set and that the images we've
been seeing on the news from the war in
ukraine are fake
is he telling lies it might be just set
up
[Music]
to fool us should we see the answer
it's fake news this video was taken in
the ukrainian capital kiev but the man's
claims that kiev is a movie set and that
there isn't a war going on in ukraine is
wrong when the video was taken the
fighting hadn't reached this part of the
city russian forces were more than 25k
away from the centre of kiev which is
why you still see people walking around
and driving their cars
so thank you very much for your help i
thought they were very very difficult
was that good
and remember if you've got a story get a
teacher to help you set up an fyi news
club at your school and who knows maybe
you'll have a new classmate showing up
soon too
[Music]
now to our series of conversations that
gives us kids a voice on the big issues
we call it conversation and this week
we're talking about bullying or are we
well thomas that's the issue not enough
of us are speaking out about being
bullied so this week we can hear from
three victims who have made it their
mission to encourage us to speak out
when we're being bullied
[Music]
i think it was decided by the world
before i discovered myself that i was
gay and
um i was picked on for it
people used to say really hurtful
comments to me about my hair and my
appearance really any part of me that
wasn't stereotypically white
they didn't think that i belonged
in this country as such so they would
just
say
go back home to where you belong
those labels were dirty words and it
made me want to hide who i was
like even till now i guess i've just
never really
processed it too much
we know that you might be feeling this
pain too
but you can turn things around
just like us i'm coming out the other
side because of the support i got i'm
proud of who i am
i'm proud of being different
i do feel pride kind of having spoken
out because
now i feel i'm much better equipped
if it were ever to happen again
one of the things about um
speaking out about homophobic bullying
to somebody including your mum
is
that in a sense you have to sort of come
out to them don't you um
and
god that was terrifying it began to turn
around um
which actually looking back and it was
it was a really big move
it just goes to show that speaking out
and sharing your experiences means that
we can beat the bullies
to show you just how helpful talking
about your experiences can be
we're going to look at some typical
bullying situations and offer some
advice
these are real cases that childline have
shared with us with the permission of
the victim
all we know is their age and what
happened
their stories have been voiced by actors
and we have given them a name
hi i'm lily and i'm 13 years old
i'm really scared of two boys at school
who keep making nasty comments about my
body and the color of my skin
they've been doing this on and off since
primary school
and now they're bullying me on the bus
to school i try not to show any emotion
when this happens so i don't want to
give them a reason to call me names
i get off the bus every day and just
break down in tears
they've even threatened to follow me
home after school
so now i get off 15 minutes from my
house even if they aren't on the bus
with me
i i might need a second that is just hit
home
that's
actually such a serious issue as well i
can understand when somebody dislikes me
because i've personally done something
wrong but when it's something to do with
your identity like your skin color it's
just it's so
it's so unfathomable i just i honestly
want this person to know that these boys
honestly
just don't know what they're saying as
someone who's been bullied
for my sexuality
which is another thing that you can't
change about yourself the best way to
overcome that is to embrace
that difference the most powerful thing
you can do is start loving that part of
yourself yeah
um and then they can't win
i would advise you to check your school
system
what sport do they have in place it's so
important that she tells somebody yeah
often just putting out in the open to
your parents i know they're your parents
but putting it out to them
validates the experience and you can
move on from that
hi i'm josh and i'm 13 years old
i'm being cyberbullied by a kid in my
class and his friends when i'm gaming
they keep annoying me on live messaging
he's very rude and always tells me to
shut up i'm scared that when i do go
back to school this boy and his friends
were all going up on me it makes me feel
worried sad and helpless i think he has
to remember that actually
um these platforms will all have rules
that you have to you have to follow yeah
and you can report things obviously
these are the people he knows maybe
reported to the school it's not like
just because it didn't happen in school
the school
cannot take that matter into their own
hands i kind of had a similar thing
where i would get put into these massive
group chats and so we kind of always
have these jokes that were banter some
of the things that were being said were
actually really hurtful
the comeback would always be you're
ruining the joke and it's
it's not a joke if you're not laughing
and i think that often people say things
online behind the protection of a screen
that they would never ever dare to say
to your face yeah i'm going to sound
like my mum but like logging off
sometimes can be
a really helpful thing but you need you
need a social media cleanse every now
and then
hi
i'm jess and i'm 12 years old
i've been getting nasty anonymous online
messages it's literally tearing me apart
at first i thought it was just something
that would pass over time but it's been
going on for a month now
i don't know what i've done to deserve
the bullying i'm getting
at first it was about my sexuality
then my weight and my looks
now it's getting more serious it's
something that serious and you report it
also
the block button is absolutely your
friend in these cases
you don't have a duty to read that she
said something which i think is a very
common thread and that's i don't know
what i did to deserve this and the
answer is you did not do anything i
cannot emphasize that enough
it's imperative that
she talks to somebody screenshot these
things as well first of all provides
evidence so you can
you know present your case when you
report it but also it takes it out of
the immediate sphere and stops it from
feeling quite so in your head give your
phone to this trusted adult and they can
see it for what's going on or even just
a mate i'm not somebody you trust
to anybody being bullied at the moment
i'd really like to encourage them to
not feel any guilt or any shame there is
the most strength
in sharing your story and in speaking
your truth and
saying that you will not be silenced
[Music]
to see more of that conversation and
watch all of our big conversations on
the big issues just head to our webpage
first dot news forward slash fyi and
click on the link there's also info on
where to go for support if you're being
bullied
as the war in ukraine continues next
week there's a special edition of fyi
here's scarlet with more on our
investigation into europe's refugee
crisis and the escape from ukraine
february 2022 and ukraine was under
attack
russian forces launched a full-scale
invasion of the country bringing water
europe for the first time in decades
millions of families were terrified
about what would happen to them
they had to flee their homes to find
somewhere safe to live and many of them
came to neighbouring countries like
poland my parents are now in ukraine and
they stay there to defend our country we
try to become and we believe in our
country and in our soldiers in this
special edition of fyi we're hearing
from ukrainian families whose lives have
been ripped apart by war i am terrified
of the thought that someday i will call
them and they will not respond
[Music]
well i suppose one good thing that's
come from this war is the amount of good
that you see
so many people across europe are
welcoming ukrainians into their homes
yeah but our government is being
criticized for being slow to end
ukrainian refugees into britain there is
still a huge amount waiting for visas
but some ukrainian families have been
letting in recent days we're going to
leave you with some images we found of
ukrainians finally being welcomed into
the uk
see you next time
hello
how are you i'm tired
[Music]